sie sprechen es an die dänen haben es
vorgemacht herr stöhr wir wollen ihnen
einmal zeigen was in der mark los ist
ich habe zumindest sehr neidisch auf
diese bilder geschaut wir jetzt
gemeinsam sehen können denn wir haben
einen kollegen von uns überallhin kite
nach kopenhagen geschickt
dänemark atmet auf mit dem freedom day
fielen am 10 september nicht nur die
masken sondern auch alle anderen corona
maßnahmen zugegeben das wetter in
kopenhagen ist zwar nicht so schön dafür
ist die stimmung hier aber umso besser
denn seitdem zehnter september ist die
massen pflicht hier gefallen mit maske
rumlaufen kann zwar noch jeder der
möchte aber ich habe das gefühl dass wir
hier kaum einer mehr oder auch ich
persönlich werde jetzt mein wochenende
ohne maske genießen
5,8 millionen dänen davon leben über
620.000 in gruppen hagen vergleichbar
mit den einwohnern von düsseldorf nur
auf einem drittel der fläche vollständig
geimpft über 75%
masken in der gastronomie fehlanzeige
aber auch sonst sieht man in dänemarks
hauptstadt kaum noch mund nasen
bedeckungen bilder die wir fast
vergessen haben egal ob im supermarkt
oder beim shoppen bilder der normalität
und das mit weiterhin niedrigen
fallzahlen
erleichterung in kopenhagen
die meisten menschen in dänemark sind
geimpft wir lebten lange mit den
maßnahmen jetzt sind wir frei und ich
fühle mich sicher und halte es nicht für
ein risiko
ich habe meine freiheit zurück ich kann
hingehen wohin ich möchte tun was ich
möchte wann ich es möchte ohne maske
oder test
doch eine frage drängt sich auf warum
sich auf deutschland diesen schritt
nicht wie denen worden
und auch das nachtleben findet hier oben
ohne statt egal ob vor den bars oder in
den klubs die hauptstadt feiert sorgen
und masten frei ich muss
die frage gestellt wie werden die dänen
nachtleben ihr partyleben an das gehirn
virus anpassen und die antwort ist klar
ist interessiert sie nicht zufriert es
gibt keine abstand es gibt keine masken
pflicht aber es scheint zu funktionieren
denn die effizienzwerte sprechen ja für
sich und da stellt sich natürlich die
frage
wie sich die frage was machen die den
besser als gedrückt das wissen wir
anders klären
du wirst uns jetzt zugeschaltet aus
kopenhagen beeindruckende bilder die du
dann mitgebracht hast auch vom
wochenende wie fühlt sich das für dich
an dort zu sein
du sagst es im grunde genommen schon
paul beeindruckende bilder und ein
beeindruckendes gefühl denn das
vermissen wir seit zwei jahren oder mehr
als drei jahren in deutschland also hier
hinzu kommen die eindrücke zu sammeln
dieses gefühl von freiheit zu haben ist
wirklich unbeschreiblich
wenn ich allein darüber nachdenken wie
das war am flughafen war es tatsächlich
auch so wie in deutschland das war
wirklich gewöhnlich für mich vor sich
und traurig als ich das sage mit maske
rumlaufen du musst einen test machen
bevor du raus ist und dann letztendlich
wenn dieser test negativ ist dann kannst
du raus auch das ist noch normal du
kannst im freien die maske abnehmen so
lange genug platz hast steigt aber dann
ins taxi auf einmal fehlt das plexiglas
der fahrrad keine maske meran wir tragen
keine maske kommen ins hotel das ist
irgendwie ein komisches gefühl es war so
ein bisschen was von unwohlsein und im
nächsten moment kam es irgendwie sowieso
ein geistesblitz in mich rein und ich
dachte mir so ey du machst gerade nichts
falsches du darfst hier ohne maske ins
hotel rein du darfst ja ohne maske ins
restaurant ein und so darf sie ohne
maske frei rumlaufen sich bewegen das
ist wirklich es fehlt mir und ich habe
es sehr genossen
das freut uns dass du das genossen hat
gleichzeitig die frage gibt es dort
denen die sagen mensch das ist
risikoreich was wir machen oder sind
alle happy und sagen super dass bei uns
schon dieser freedom day war das wir
machen können was wir wollen wieder
also ich habe es jetzt zu beginn des
beitrages auch in dem aufsager gesagt du
kannst natürlich noch die maske tragen
wenn du es magst und es gibt hier die
eine oder andere person ich könnte sie
aber jetzt an der hand abzählen wie
viele es letztendlich waren die gesagt
haben ich gehe auf nummer sicher ich
möchte die maske doch lieber anziehen
und das ist das ist auch vollkommen okay
für die dänen ihr also die sind ja auch
vollkommen fein mit die leute die eine
maske tragen wollen können sie gerne
tragen aber ich glaube was hier so
mitschwingt ist die freude dass man halt
eben auch ohne maske auflaufen kann und
wie haben sie den beitrag gesehen der
großteil wird als einfach ohne maske
rumlaufen überleben vielen dank und ich
wünsche dir noch eine schöne party nacht
ohne maske in kopenhagen herzlichen dank
karl lauterbach also wir sehen die
impfquote ist nicht weit aus höher in
denen markt als in deutschland aber
alles ist frei warum geht das nicht bei
uns man kann aus rechnen also ab wann
das klima in dem sinn also im
wesentlichen also gibt es eine vorne wo
man ausrechnen kann wie viele games
zahlen müssen gegeben wie hoch der wert
des virus ist und also wie stark die
impfungen wirken auch so aus diese vorne
kann man ungefähr ausrechnen wie viele
games sein müssen und die haben wir
wollen noch mal vergleichen die zahlen
wir haben die vorbereitet wir haben
vorbereitet der im vergleich deutschland
und dänemark wir sind was diese zahlen
angeht im vergleich zu dänemark
tatsächlich auf ähnlichem gleichen
niveau
lauterbach warum können wir dann nicht
den nicht auf gleichem niveau also der
unterschied ist ungefähr wenn ich jetzt
nur auf diejenigen schaue die noch nicht
games sind dann ist der anteil derer die
also als unter den erwachsenen noch
nicht gibt sind in deutschland ungefähr
doppelt so hoch man unterschätzt dass
wenn also jetzt einmal in bei den
erwachsenen ungefähr die quote in
dänemark bei 85 prozent liegt und bei
uns liegt sie bei den erwachsenen bei
ungefähr 70 prozent etwas über 70
prozent dann ist das die doppelte quote
und das ist so ähnlich wenn das hier
sind diese formel 1 geht das wenn der
erwerb doppelt so hoch wäre somit für
den laien also klingt das ungefähr
klingt 75 so ähnlich wie 85 na ja so
ungefähr als größtes 50 ist und der
dimension kommen wir uns doch schon nach
aber ich will die zahlen einmal mehr das
stimmt dass wir uns die einmal genau
anschauen können den vergleich
deutschland und dänemark also hier sehen
wir deutschland und dänemark im
vergleich da sehen wir die korona
neuinfektionen der letzten 30 tage und
wir sehen dass sich seit freedom day in
dänemark eben nichts wirklich nach oben
entwickelt hat frau stimmt ist das etwas
wo wir uns eigentlich ein beispiel
nehmen sollten herrnsheimer das ist doch
völlig klar die frage wie die dänen und
auch andere länder jetzt mit der
pandemie umgehen oder auch sich während
der pandemie verhalten haben ist doch
eine rein politische ja also die länder
haben ist unterschiedlich gelöst ihre
probleme und wir haben gesehen dass es
geht so man hat sich in deutschland
dafür entschieden weiterhin den kurs der
zurückhaltung zu fahren liegt das an der
kanzlerin an ihrer kanzlerin unter
anderem ja warum ist das natürlich das
kann ich ihnen nicht sagen das müssen
sie diejenigen selbst fragen wir fragen
uns das ja alle selbst auch ja ich bin
ja auch ein mensch ich bin auch bürgerin
ich habe auch eine familie und kleine
kinder und frage mich natürlich auch
warum kommen wir nicht raus aus dieser
situation warum sind wir das land der
bedenkenträger an dieser frage was ja
und ich und was erleben wir stattdessen
herr lauterbach was erleben sie und da
haben sie auch da tragen sie auch
mitverantwortung ein land das sich immer
mehr in die spaltung bewegt ein land das
schlechtes gewissen verbreitet dass
menschen die nicht geimpft sind aus
welchen gründen auch immer das steht
jedem frei in diesem land in eine ecke
gestellt werden die diffamiert werden
und letztendlich dazu führt dass der
friede auch in unserer gesellschaft
immer mehr gefährdet wird und das macht
mir sorge aber sind doch große worte die
die realität also was man sich nicht
wirklich schreiben die realität ist doch
wir haben im gegensatz zu dänemark oder
im gegensatz zu portugal haben wir sie
eben nicht die hohe impfquote die einen
fehler erlauben würde da sorgt die
einzige das noch die die schnelle
wahrheit
[Musik]